welcome to the broadcast this is Hans
Kim I am a very very
funny person in some ways
uh uh I'm just here answering questions
and talking about life and love and
everything in between
so let's first answer
this question
hey
uh there's something that someone said
that bothered me
I forget what it was
I guess everything people say bothers me
some people just text me they think they
can just abuse me
in the in the uh whatever
but you know a lot of people don't abuse
me
some people are nice to me and I just
focus on the people that abuse me I
guess
hi Riley
so pretty
thank you
of course Riley's never abusive
um I love Michigan great state
very weird politically they got a
Democratic governor and then a super
right-wing militia it's like they got
rednecks and hippies all mixed together
up there I don't know what you guys are
doing
but it's weird it's a weird mix you guys
got both ends of the political Spectrum
warring with each other
I don't kill Tony was super fantastic
keep up uh oh the video went out
oh I think the battery died I forgot to
plug it in
one second please
wait is that the video
I don't know what's happening
foreign
that's my clothes
but uh good to be here uh Tony does this
song when he brings me up
this is on skin this is Hans Kim or
something
uh and it's just I never even realized
he did it until people told me in Naples
Florida actually
they told me that he did that and I was
like I never knew that because I was
just too busy walking up on stage to
notice
yeah I'm in the zone
I'm like a football player getting ready
to tackle his opponents
I'm the warrior entering into the arena
to the Coliseum
I am a
a soldier
how do you how do I talk to other Comics
at Mike's
I would say go up to him and be like hey
what's up
you come up with any tags recently
how those punch lines going
and uh you know talk to them about
themselves because they love talking
about themselves
and then just be like if you want to
smoke some weed
oh okay
and then you have a new best friend
talking to Comics is easy
they're really selfish
selfish little people
um
what's up uh Hans are you in Austin yes
I'm in Austin Texas right now home of
me and Joe Rogan and Tony Hinchcliffe
uh yeah I'm in Austin I love it here you
know it's like Texas is pretty firmly
Republican and then Austin is like its
own weird little thing like what's the
capital
and we're like doing weird hippie [ __ ]
here so it's like even though
Republicans rule we are control the base
of operations we have the hippies in
here
so that's a weird little mix of hippies
in a red state
but you know it's not just about
politics it's just like a very creative
interesting place where like people can
do whatever they want which is nice
there's a six and a half long video of
YouTube of you smacking lips with
hotties on kill Tony and I had to turn
it off yesterday after two minutes
because I was getting too jealous
well you know it's good that you
recognized the feeling of envy and
jealousy popping up in front of you and
you're able to control your environment
to limit that
um